6500 euros par an c'est le coût de
location de cette bande de
téléconsultations médicales à plaisir
une technologie inaugurée ce mardi 16
novembre pour répondre à la
problématique de désertification
médicale ce service permet de mettre en
relation patient et médecin objectif
éviter d'encombrer les urgences
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de médecins
généralistes disponibles le rendez vous
se déroule en visio une habitude depuis
la crise sanitaire l'accord vise aussi à
fait que aujourd'hui on en est on aime
moins peut-être aller dans des endroits
encombré où il ya beaucoup de monde qui
fait la queue en cours des des choses
assez grave bien sûr donc ça c'est une
possibilité qui offre une liberté et
puis aussi une confidentialité qui est
importante une personne est présente au
côté de la machine le but accompagner
les patients dans leurs démarches et
désinfecter le matériel c'est bien que
quelqu'un soit là d'abord pour nettoyer
désinfecter là les petits appareils qui
sont mis à disposition et puis aussi
parce que il faut pas que les personnes
soient en plus de leurs petites
pathologies généré inquiète par rapport
à cette même technologie de la société
medad hommes la borne est implantée à la
maison des familles flora tristan dans
une salle dédiée un rendez vous est
possible toutes les 10 minutes en
moyenne grâce à une centaine de médecins
partenaires vous arrivez donc
avec votre carte vitale
une carte bleue un numéro de portable
pour pouvoir vous connecter à votre
compte et la téléconsultation pouvoir
démarrer vous allez vous retrouver face
à un médecin en chair et en os certes
derrière un écran mais qui va donc
pouvoir établir un diagnostic et vous
donner une réponse médicale une
consultation prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale restent à la charge du
patient 7 euros 50